[Music]
my name is Kai Ricci I'm a data engineer
at sculpture just here in New York City
I'm gonna talk about kubernetes native
workflows with Argo
just a quick agenda just giving some
context about what we're trying to do
with Skillshare and the problem we're
trying to solve going a little bit about
tool selection and some alternatives we
looked at and then finally talked about
Argo itself or some details about about
it and our experiences using it all
right so so that's culture we have a
pretty small data team there's three
data scientists one data engineer that's
me we are hiring by the way and we're
wearing a larger online learning startup
so Skillshare is a community of learners
and teachers on creative topics so stuff
like drawing photography design if at
the end of this this two days you feel
like you need a break from from data
stuff and you want to do something
creative I'd encourage you to check it
out so we have like pretty small data
right now just in the tens of terabytes
but we have like a few different use
cases so like did many data teams at
small startups we're doing multiple
things so data analytics is a big one
looking at like user behavior setting up
dashboards analyzing experiments we're
also doing some at Mel's so we have a
recommender and are have many ideas for
more models for things like like content
content evaluation and you know
community stuff so and then finally we
do have to do some integrations so just
like moving data to different business
tools like Volusia for email marketing
Zendesk I mean this is typically not
something that you would associate with
the data science team but usually at you
know small startups like ours that we
were the ones who end up doing it so I
joined scull chair earlier this year and
at this one I joined we had some like
standalone infrastructure pieces like we
had a data warehouse that was getting
some data into it somewhat and
frequently we had a lot of scripts being
run on laptops we had that one server
that you SSH into and run your scripts
so what we really needed was like a
place to run all of these different like
ETL toss so extracting data loading in
different places transforming it doing
like model training running our
integrations between tools and we also
needed something to orchestrate all of
those tasks into workflows so just to
give you an example of the kind of stuff
that we're doing I mean this is a little
bit contrived because we probably won't
be running all of this off of a single
workflow but it's just sort of giving
you a flavor for the type of tasks that
we're doing so you know extracting data
from different places transforming it
maybe training a recommender rerunning
some experimenting alysus and like
pushing some user analytics to our
marketing tool right so this is how not
to do tool selection I think the best
way to do to the selection is just to
find a couple of guiding principles and
then evaluate tools like through that
lens so our first guiding principle was
was operability and so I have here can
less than one person or more than one
person operate it so what I mean by less
than one person is one person not
working on it full-time I have a theory
that if you have like one smart person
doing a heroic effort like you could
they can basically make anything
continue to run but then if they're not
working out a full-time it may fall
apart and then also if more than one
person needs to work on something and
you can't coordinate that then you're
also not in a great place so I'm like
the things that we were looking for
basically like low conceptual complexity
so we were okay with what sort of
technical complexity but we wanted to
kind of minimize the total number of
moving parts so that people could
actually like reason about the system in
a way without you know without having to
like look at a giant you know confluence
talk that's like here the 18 different
parts of our data platform and same
deployment and development of workflows
was really important to us so I think
this is like a pretty underrated
component of just data tools in
it's like hey can I actually deploy it
on my local I mean can I develop it on
my local machine and and run it in a
similar way that's gonna run in
production can I do a deployment without
stuff breaking and then just little
things like logs and metric secrets
management you know these are all sort
of stuff that I think people kind of
think of this is nice to haves or like
after the fact stuff but we wanted to
really make sure that we had all of that
place all of that in place from the
start and then our second guiding
principle just reliability so does it do
workload on how they're supposed to run
so for that you need like explicit
dependencies between steps you never you
don't want to have anything that's just
assuming something else has run and also
we kind of wanted to avoid doing too
much like polling or using like web
hooks and things you know we wanted to
have a workflow system or like one thing
directly led into another it's important
to us to decouple or execution logic and
our orchestration logic so sometimes
when people are using stuff like air
flow or Luigi you know depending on how
they're how they're using it but they
can you can sort of couple like what's
supposed to run with with when it's
supposed to run and we wanted to just
have those things be completely separate
so for each of the tasks what it's
actually doing should be like sort of
irrelevant from like you know what's
triggering it whether it's an a workflow
system or some other workflow system or
we were just like running a step
manually so which we don't want to do
but and then finally like we wanted
something that could that could scale
through like pretty big data volume
increase and this is just kind of
something that's you know we're starting
from a small point but we are a grown
States startup we our customer base is
growing pretty quickly you're over a
year and then also we just have a lot
more instrumentation once you start
giving people data tools they want to
use them and they want to like put more
data into the system and then more users
meaning more internal users so again
once you give people ways to build build
workflows and build pipelines they're
gonna start doing that on
some things we didn't really care about
right now so graphical creation of
Doug's didn't care so much about
programmatically generated Doug's and
permissioning insecurities like at this
stage where we're at right now it's it's
basically you know everyone and on the
data team has access to everything so we
didn't need a permission model this is
what we definitely didn't want this so
if you're a data scientist you've you
probably sent this message to someone
and if your data journey you've
definitely gotten this lag message from
someone so so we one of our first
decisions was to build to build a door
by so we looked at bender tools I mean
nothing that we're doing is particularly
unique right like doing ETL and and even
doing integrations between tools and is
not like a something that's specific to
us but we didn't find like any any
single vendor that did everything we
wanted and we kind of wanted to avoid
like mixing and matching tools cuz it's
really hard to do reliably like if
you're doing your ETL in one place and
you're doing your well you know with one
tool or you're doing your mo with
another tool and then you have some
internal scripts that are running short
of orchestrating all of those can be
really difficult because a lot of vendor
fools like don't really have fully
fledged api's for doing things like
notifying you when something is done or
you know even sometimes when something
is failed it's like you just get an
email or something and that's that's not
really what you want also development
can be kind of tricky with vendor tools
like you know if some good good tools
will have like let you spin up a
development environment in a sandbox
environment or production environment
and all of them do and then deploying
changes across multiple tools at the
same time can be can be really tricky so
you know if you're if you're using a
managed tool for ETL you have to make
sure that when you know our and another
managed tool for MLR you're doing em all
in-house you have to make sure that
those things are changes to the both of
those are coordinated and that can be
tricky and basically for the stuff that
we were doing we like the tasks the kind
of tasks that we were doing the
extraction the transformation we felt
pretty comfortable using open-source
tools or in some case just writing code
for them and some of the pieces were
already written so our recommendation
system was like already written out and
can
so since we decided okay we're gonna
we're gonna do some of the stuff you
know we're gonna run run this stuff on
our own platform we definitely wanted to
use containers I don't think there's any
reason to just be like running code
outside of a container in 2019 in a
production environment and so we we
built containers for a small set of
initial tests needed a place to run them
our SRE team hooked us up
it's a kubernetes cluster so they they
help this provision it and they're
they're helping us sort of Co maintain
it that's a really big thing I mean I'm
not going to understate the the sort of
maintenance effort and the difficulty of
provisioning kubernetes in the first
place so if you're you know having that
already done for us was was a huge help
and something we want to take advantage
of and you know there's just lots of
benefits but using kubernetes if you are
going to be running containers scaling
is the big one of course but again even
small things like secrets management
it's really easy to have like parity
between different environments because
the whole environment is just you know a
piece of code and you can run kubernetes
like we all have kubernetes just running
locally on our laptops and with the same
sort of configuration as Ice Cube in
production just with different
environment variables and it also has
good integration of a data dog which is
useful so all right so all right we were
like okay we're gonna use containers
we're gonna use kubernetes how are we
gonna orchestrate it so our first
thought was to use airflow but we
weren't enthusiastic about it for a few
reasons so many airflow is like pretty
complex you know there's there's a lot
of moving parts there's the UI the
schedule or the executors you can have
message buses and and it's kind of full
of at least in my experience like it's
full of foot guns meaning ways that you
can just if you're not using it
correctly you can shoot yourself in the
foot and we're not going to be using
most of the the features right if we're
just using a single executor we're not
going to be taking advantage of the sort
of UI components that you know we're not
going to be taking advantage of
permission anything like we wanted
something
that was that was simpler so that's
where our NGO comes in
so what is Argo so it's a open source
kubernetes workflow engine it's built by
by intuitive TurboTax fame or infamy as
the case may be but it has a lot of
contributors outside it into it and it's
pretty active there's new releases like
every couple of months and so Argo is
actually a set of projects there's
there's two that we were interested in
Argo workflows which is the way to
define and run workflows and then argue
events which is just a sort of flexible
event system for kubernetes that we used
to trigger workflows Argo also has
components for doing like CI CD but we
that wasn't really relevant to our use
case so what does kubernetes a native
mean so workflows and events are defined
as as custom resource definitions and
kubernetes meaning that they're
basically knit like sort of like native
kubernetes objects and they can orange
resources and they can interface very
easily with other resources so secrets
config naps volume mounts and workflows
take full advantage of like the
kubernetes scheduling so you can do like
affinity didn't be obtained some
toleration x' set resource limits so
here's an example of what an Argo
workflow looks like so first thing
you'll notice is that it's defined any
animal just like and every other
criminalities resource that depending on
how you feel that can either be like a
positive thing or a negative thing for
for me I think it's pretty positive
because basically means that the
workflow is declarative there's no sort
of execution of or you know like
imperative execution of steps and in the
same way that you would have with like a
dag that was written in Python and so
the the workflows steps are just
container images and you can basically
just declared a view declaratively
define a dot so in this case we have
like two extractions and then a
transformation and we just define the
the dependency between information is
dependent on the extraction steps
and you know when you execute it it'll
run the extraction steps first and then
run the transformation which is pretty
pretty nifty so there's a couple of ways
to run a workflow like in for
development you can just use there's a
command line tool called Argo which is a
just a wrapper around cheap CTL so these
workflows again since they are just
kubernetes resources you can use keep
CTL to create them and turn them down if
you want but argo has a nice CLI tool so
you can you know you just you can submit
a workflow it'll run this is a sort of
very small example from earlier gives
you some nice output as you can see
there's a pod name for each step of the
workflow so each each workflows each of
each of those containers is being
scheduled into a pod
so there's complete isolation between
them and also if you can use any of your
existing kubernetes logging monitoring
whatever you're using to so just get the
output of each of these steps there's
some advanced features so you can
there's parameter passing so you can you
can pass parameters from the command
line you can pass parameters between
between different tasks so like the
output of one task can be a parameter
into another task
there's artifacts so you can output an
artifact from one step and so this this
path here is like the place in the the
container after it finishes running
where you want to pull the artifact from
and then you can kind of reference that
in another as an input to another task
and we under the hood it just you can
you can hook it up to a artifact store
so either Mineo or s3 and it just kind
of seamlessly handles that so that's
that's really nice I think we were not
using this feature so much right now but
I think it's just it's a pretty nice
feature and and certainly like because
our goal was originally a sort of
oriented toward CI CD I mean this is
something that kick came out of that
world but we find it pretty useful you
know for for data workflows as well
so there's some just a couple of I'm
just gonna go through like some
miscellaneous features that we really
like so there's memorize resubmit
meaning that if you're if your workflow
fails you can resubmit it and not rerun
any of the existing steps just pretty
easily you can suspend and resume
workflows so if you have something
that's ticking read the time you want to
dispose it again especially like on your
you know your local machine you can just
suspend it and then resume it later and
then you can also suspend workflows
within the task definitions so kind of
like having a like press ENTER to
continue or something and that can be
that can be helpful in some cases like
for example if you know there's
something incomplete data or is some
validation that needs to be done before
like if you need to validate something
before you want to continue along with
it you can just add a suspense step
inside the task let's see there's many
many other features there's cite cars
and daven containers so side cars are
basically companion containers to each
of the workflow steps so if you have you
know you don't need to have just a
single container per workflows step I
mean it's just for simplicity I think
it's pretty useful to to do that but you
don't need to and the daemon container
is pretty cool it basically means that
throughout the entire lifecycle of the
workflow you have a you have a container
running so you can use this for like if
you want to have a database for example
that all of your workflow steps are
accessing you can just spend that up in
a daemon container and you know like
have your your individual tasks right
into that into that database and then do
some aggregation at the end so this is
if you're doing sort of more you know
MapReduce type stuff without or just
something that needs like dedicated
infrastructure to run you can you can
use the daemon container there's all
sorts of dag genetic ins like
conditional tasks subtags generated Dex
loops recursive dives we generally try
and
stay away from stuff like this because
again if we're going for operability and
reliability I mean I think as as your
gags kind of get more complicated and
start including logic and dynamic
generation that can definitely like
create some problems for you but if you
need to do that kind of stuff you can
either is also like partial you can do
like partial dad groans in a similar way
that you would do with with airflow post
run hooks moving a pretty
straightforward and after after a step
runs or after the Holbrooke full run so
you can do stuff like send a slack
message or update something else you can
also create kubernetes resources as a
task I think for the data use case I I
haven't figured out where this would be
useful but I'm sure some creative people
in the audience can kind think of a use
for this so yeah you can like as a TAS
you can create you can spin up a pot or
you know create a config map or
something
there is a UI it's pretty it's pretty
primitive the astute audience members
will notice so this is not the the same
dog that I showed before as an example
but it's just a screenshot from the
Internet we don't really use the UI that
much I mean basically all it does is
show you the what would ran and if you
click into any of these boxes that will
just show you the logs for that step we
find it easier to just use the CLI tool
but the Argo is working the Oracle
project is working on the UI they're
definitely planning on adding features
like you know kicking I know right now I
don't think you can even like kick off a
workflow from the UI so if you do want
something with you I don't think this is
the right project for you yet maybe in
the future
all right so I'm going to talk a little
bit about triggering so the examples I
showed earlier where like running
workflow is just from the command line
obviously you don't want to do that in
production you want to have a
programmatic way to trigger your events
so this is where argue events comes in
it's actually not part of our workflows
it's like a companion project so you can
you can use Argo workflows without any
of this event triggering stuff and you
can even so you can either use a
command-line tool there's also a Web API
I think that's built into our the
workflows so if you want to if you want
to just hook this stuff up to your you
know if you have an existing system that
you're using to to trigger stuff you can
but if you want to use our go events
it's pretty flexible you know there's
lots of different ways to trigger things
like you know holding a git repository
web hooks schedules let's that's what we
use right now to just hit the top of our
tags but lots of different options and
there's there's also sort of you can use
some pretty sophisticated logic so like
this only see where the pointer thing is
yeah so these these things are are
basically sensors that will listen to
events and you can see the different
sensors so listen to multiple events at
once so you could have something that's
like checking on is scheduled and
triggered by it some other thing and you
can you can combine the logic either
using like you know just anzen or is
just to set up some pretty sophisticated
triggering and these things these little
octopus dudes down here are whoops let
me go back these are your actual
workflows so I'm not gonna give the code
examples of that right now because it's
a little head doesn't and it's not that
interesting I don't think but the
capability is there and so one thing I
wanted to talk to touch on is its
packaging and deployment so that was
kind of one of the things about that we
wanted it in terms of operability so
because we're and I think this was
really cool because we're close in
events our kubernetes resources we can
just use helm to deploy it an upgrade
workflows which is like really nice so
we package up all like free every
workflow that we have we have an
individual package for it so the the
source again is just like gamo files and
github
and then we can use we can also in that
same repository define define it as a
home package so that means that like if
we wanted to let's say deploy something
you know to QA we can just use home to
upgrade the existing workflows and one
nice thing is that it'll actually like
if workflows are already in progress
it'll just continue to run them under
the old verge under the old version so
you don't have to like worry too much
about when you upgrade stuff like with
air flow if you're upgrading if you're
upgrading DAGs sometimes like the new
dag will be running what when you think
the old dag is running or vice-versa
helm does like a pretty nice job of just
you know not upgrading things until the
the workflows don't actually that's not
that's not a helmet eacher that's just
something that oreo does but this also
makes like dev and QA and prop
deployments very seamless because let's
say we wanted to test out this this new
version of this of this workflow in dev
we would just do like a helm upgrade
against our our local dev clusters
running on our laptop and you rerun the
workflow see how it works and same thing
in a QA environment and this can also be
useful if you're like if you're worried
about interactions between workflows
because then you can rather than just
packaging up inter-individual workflows
in our case our work clothes are like
pretty separate so we just package them
up individually but if you want to have
like a big a big set of workflows you
can also package those up together and
then like deploy that to a QA
environment and see if there's any like
hidden interactions between like your
new your new version of one workflow
with with another workflow that's in the
same package so yeah I think that's
that's a really cool feature it makes
makes my life very easy because you know
if I need to deploy something it's it's
literally just one line so just I'll
just talk about our implementation
experience so it took us like about a
week of I did full time engineering work
to set up or go it's not like a just
completely out of the box thing and then
you have to most of the documentation
for our go
poses like in the github page itself
there's not a lot of like standalone
documentation argue events actually
house quite a bit of stand-alone
documentation but you know it's not a
it's not an out-of-the-box solution also
just as a caveat you know we already had
kubernetes set up I mean that's that's a
pretty big thing I would sort of say to
you if you are not running kubernetes at
all setting up kubernetes and setting up
Agro at the same time is maybe a little
ambitious and something you should think
about carefully but if you already I
have kubernetes set up I mean I
definitely like check out or go but the
trade-off I think here is like it's more
time up front but then the operational
time has been cut down a lot I mean
we've been running to production tags
with around 20 tasks so I mean
definitely not like a huge volume of
tags but these are things that run like
every hour for the past six months and I
think we have like one production outage
where one of our underlying nodes failed
and a workflow home which is in theory
something kubernetes should be able to
handle and self-heal from but it didn't
in this case but that was just fixed by
like a pretty simple restart and use
data dog for log aggregation again
that's it's really useful to have the
output of all of your all of your
workflows in a single place and you can
set up filters just so like if you're
doing proper logging or you know you're
using like block levels and stuff like
we just have an alert that if there's if
there's an error in any of in any of the
workflow logs that well we'll get
notified and so there's there's a couple
of things that are go can't do right now
that we that we wish it could do so the
big one is like you can't limit like
top-level got concurrency meaning for a
given dag you can't say only one of the
Stags should run at a time that can be
an issue it's like time triggered time
trigger we're closed right so if you
have if you have something that's
running every hour and for some reason
it takes two hours to run you will get a
second copy of it at the end of the next
hour that could be I mean that could be
a deal breaker that's something that
we've worked around for now you can
definitely adjust concurrency within
within the workflow itself so there's
task concurrency but at a global level
there's no way to limit it like that
concurrency and then like I've mentioned
earlier argue events is a little complex
there's a few different objects involved
there's the events the gateways and the
sensors we kind of toughed it out and
set it up but you know you can just
trigger the work flows through an API if
you want that maybe may be easier for
some some people does anyone have any
questions and before that let me just
give a quick plug so we're hiring two
data scientists one analytics focus 1ml
focused and a data engineer so if you're
interested working with some of this
stuff please come see me after the talk
but otherwise that's it hey if I wanted
to do some sorts of can retest things
between two models is that possible to
implement it in cargo as well cannery or
a be testing any sorts of well so let's
see I mean you could you could implement
it in or go
but basically you it doesn't have any
like built in in future to do that it
would basically have to like run two
things two models in a workflow and then
have some sort of like you know the post
run stuff that sends the output
somewhere in you and you can compare
them but really it's just like a it's
just a way of sort of running containers
in a certain order so I mentioned
earlier with the being able to spin up
the pod separate pods and then having to
spin down based on specifying tests that
would be probably more useful right yeah
right so you can yeah so you could like
so by default possible just and like
when when the the task ends but you can
also like you can sort of exit pods
early if you want within when the task
itself if you'd wanted to I'm not sure
if that's your question
yeah well and then there are there
resource cleaning when yeah yeah so it's
there's garbage there's garbage
collection of resources right so you can
you can so we actually we let our pods
sit around for a little bit because we
want to have them in case we want to
like go back and just like see what
happened and more detailed but yeah you
know you can just set
that stuff to just go away as soon as
the workflow ends and the worst question
is are there any metrics alerting
besides the dog yeah I mean so we do
doesn't have any like built-in metric
stuff
itself so yeah you need you need to
bring that yourself so yeah we used a
dog both at the cluster level and then
with an individual task so hi so first
of all thanks for the talk yeah so I had
two questions sure so I'm an avid
airflow user so that's a disclaimer okay
so firstly can you backfill dag runs
using our goal there's no yeah it's that
that functionality is definitely not as
as picked out is in her flow I mean you
would basically you can sort of you'd
have to do it yourself by like
parameterizing your dog run and you know
you can pass in like a start date and
end date but yeah it doesn't it doesn't
really have any built-in notion of like
tying and the same idea door flow does
okay okay fair enough and the other one
is how do you test your DAGs cuz it's ya
know Mouse so air flow tags are Pisan so
they're easy to test in a sense yeah so
we for testing we kind of we use like
basically like a data of validation
approach for real will we use like data
tests so we go look at what the output
should be and then write tests against
that we don't actually test the dag
logic itself I mean most of our dogs are
pretty simple and we're more interested
in like the output than anything else so
it's kind of like integration test
versus you know to us
[Music]